بالنسبة لسكان بيروت ،
انقسمت الحياة الآن بين ما حدث من
قبل
وما حدث بعد أن التقط أحد موظفي
صالة باربل هاوس
هذه الصور على هاتفه
ولم يصب بأذى ،
شيفا كارت هي مدربة في صالة الألعاب الرياضية بمجرد
أن رأيت أن شيئًا لم يحدث لي
صعدنا ركضنا
إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية في محاولة لبدء مساعدة
الناس
وأصيب الكثير من الناس ، وكان الكثير من الناس على الأرض
مشوشين ، أخذناهم للتو
ووضعناهم في الخارج
وأخذوهم إلى المستشفى بعد
أقل من يومين والدماء
لا تزال موجودة  على الأوزان ،
يقوم أعضاء الصالة الرياضية برفع الأشياء الثقيلة
لاستعادة مظهر من الروتين
في الكنيسة المارونية المارونية ،
يقوم القس بإجراء قداس مباشر
يقطعه الزلزال ثم
تحطم الزجاج
المحطم كان الأب مروان ملواد جالسًا في
المقاعد  وافترضنا على الفور أنه كان
اغتيالًا سياسيًا في الشوارع
بالخارج ،
اعتقدنا أن الله ينقذنا ، حفظنا الله ، يتذكر
أننا أردنا الخروج من هنا
بأقل قدر ممكن من الضرر
gla  شظايا ss في المقاعد
فارغة في الغالب مساء الثلاثاء بسبب
قيود فيروس كورونا ،
تم إنقاذ لوحين من الزجاج الملون أحدهما
يصور
المسيح الآخر مار شربل ، وهو قديس لبناني
مشهور بمعجزات
ليست معجزة ، ولكن ربما يكون بصيص
أمل في أن روح لبنان بعيدة عن
الانهيار.
عرض حي في
شوارع ميخائيل المجنون
المزدحمة في الحي المجاور للميناء
تم التضحية بالمسافة الاجتماعية في
محاولة للتشبث بروح المجتمع
في أرض يعتمد نظام الحكم
فيها على الانقسامات
بين 18
دينيًا معترفًا بها رسميًا في البلاد  طوائفهم
قاموا بعملهم في اليوم الذي
يتجه فيه طاقم متطوع مخصص إلى المنزل
يغني أغنية شعبية مع الإزاحة
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سيعود لبنان
، المدينة
مجروحه تنزف وتضرب لكنها غير مقننة بن ويدمان cnn
بيروت